hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
resolving challenges in flow cytometry
panel design
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by beckmann culture life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
matthew goff commercial product manager
at beckmann culture life sciences
and dr michael kapinski senior marketing
manager at beckmann culture life
sciences
matthew you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for the kind introduction
so welcome everybody to today to this
webinar on how we would propose to
resolve challenges in flow cytometry
panel design
so in order to address these challenges
it makes sense to think about the
antigens first so how would we match the
expression level of the given antigens
that we want to detect with the choice
of fluorochromes that we have
and the related furogram brightnesses
but also
we want to be conscious here of the
spill over that is related to this
choice
and after that in the second section i
would like to
give a little bit a more holistic view
not only thinking about the
fluorochromes and the isolated antigen
expression densities but also think
about the expression patterns so what is
the biology that is underlying this and
how would this combined fuel
on biology fluorochrome emissions and
light detection would help us
to understand
how data spreading
could occur and how we could avoid data
spreading
and after that my colleague mike
matt is taking over
and will further elaborate on the
dimension of the instrumentation so what
is on the instrumentation side of things
when it comes to
antibody
application panel design
so let's start with the antigens and the
fluorochromes first
here we see a lineup of different
commonly used fluorochromes
from left to right with regard to their
relative brightness on the left we might
look at small organic dyes like pacific
blue chrome orange
and also
percipi as a very traditional dye and as
we move to the right
to brighter dyes we find fitc
then a first tandem die of pe which is
ecd another tandem of apc
a large fluorescent protein also apc
alexa 750 so combination of fluorescent
proteins basically a small organic dyes
which is referred to as tandem dyes and
further on the right you see more tandem
dyes even brighter and also pe
and now as a more recent
die to consider here a more recent class
of dyes to consider we have the polymer
dice where you see
a representant of this group of dyes in
the upper row
the supernova
violet for 28. so if we think about
which die to select for a certain
antigen expression density it seems
obvious that for those antigens that
have a low number of copies on the cell
surface we would rather select a die
that sits in the right part of this
diagram that has a strong and it is
really bright that gives a high signal
even with the
relatively small number of labeled
antigens
whereas for a very strongly expressed
antigen such a strong lineage marker
we would rather choose a die that sits
in the left part of the diagram here
but when we think of the
expression density of a dye of a certain
antigen we should also consider the
characteristics of this expression
so
what does that mean if we look at this
overlay plot here and the very lowest
row and at the bottom we see
a typical
bimodal expression this could be for
instance unt lymphocyte cd4 we have
hundred thousands of copies here on the
positive population
and this one is very clearly and very
discreetly separated from the negative
population as we move up one level here
we see a typical modulated antigen
which probably is the most difficult to
handle in panel design as we see very
bright
our cells that have a very dense
expression and also cells that have a
very low expression density for this
antigen so this kind of want to make us
using a dye that is bright and dim at
the same time which of course does not
exist
um so here this is the most
uh challenging choice we have to take
when considering the dies
balancing this these expression
densities very well against uh
brightness of the dye
one line above we see weak antigen
expression so this would be a typical
candidate for using a very strong dye
and above which is labeled here
ironically as you need to believe
this would not only be a weak expression
density but also a very low frequency so
very low number
of
events that are specifically positive
so this would
require that you take basically our
brightest story that we have at our
disposal for this kind
of antigen expression patterns
but once we have made a selection
uh we should also think a little bit
beyond this just single signal that we
might obtain as with this single signal
and especially specifically with very
bright signals
we will see that there are spillover
associated into other parts of the
spectrum and this
spillover will impact the resolution and
effective separation
for sickness that we want to measure
on these other detectors in these other
spectral ranges
how could this be understood and
explained i'm using here
the poisson distribution as a model for
the detection of photons
and what we see on the left is as the
curve moves on the right on the x-axis
the
curve is also flattening so it's getting
broader
and this basically reflects the rule
that as the number
of two photons increases
which is shown by the probability
function on the right where we won't go
into detail but as this number is
increasing
the probability that i exactly detect
these number of true photons is
decreasing so this is basically the
flattening of the curve
the detection device will not be able to
distinguish between wanted photons from
a certain emission
from unwanted photons that are basically
spill over into the same range of the
spectrum
so it will only
lump together these photons
and
this will
result in the fact that as
more and more photons are detected
as we move more and more on the
to the right side of the x-axis here in
the diagram on the left the curve will
flatten the distribution will be broader
so the precision
will
be compromised the more photos detected
which is the sum of a primary signal and
the spillover and the detector will not
make a difference between those the
broader this distribution this poisson
distribution will be so this is
basically the spreading that we are
observing
how does this look in real life so
here's a cd4 stain on the left with a
relatively dim organic dye chrome orange
we see that the signal separation is not
overwhelmingly bright but very discrete
and clear we will be able
to
see what is the cd4 positive cell here
and was what is this cd4 negative cell
so it's just bright enough for what we
want to achieve
on the right we have a very strong dye
so
ppe fluorescent protein very bright
um labeled to the same antibody
detecting cd4 and they get a much
stronger separation maybe 500 times as
strong or 300 times as strong however
still we can only distinguish between
cd4 negative and positive
but we are compromising the resolution
that we can obtain on the cd4 positive
population
in the 6 20 30 channel on the same laser
so we see there is a broadening of the
distribution we have a lot of spill over
this adds to the signal or the overall
sum of photons that we are detecting
in the y-axis or in the channel on the
y-axis and so we are compromising or we
are limiting
the sensitivity that we can obtain
on the cd4 positive population in such a
range of the spectrum or in such a
detector so
cd4 is much brighter here much stronger
separated but is it really better i
think we can clearly see that it's not
better it's worse so this is not a good
match
of antigen brightness and fluorochrome
choice on the right while it's pretty
pretty okay and pretty fine on the left
so this brings us to this goldilocks
principle of dye brightness we want to
really match the need for sensitivity or
we want to balance the need for
sensitivity for a certain antigen being
detected with the spillover that is
associated and that might compromise
other of the detection of other antigens
due to the spillover and spreading that
is basically
caused by this so we want to really
balance that having just the right dye
brightness to be sensitive enough but to
not compromise the detection of
other antigens in the same antibody
panel
the same goldilocks principle can be
imagined or can be envisioned here in
this diagram
this could be a model that helps a
little bit to work along this goldilocks
principle so on the x-axis we see a
staining index and on the y-axis we see
a compensation requirement
and we see that a certain area is
indicated here as optimal this is an
area where the staining index has a
minimal number at least on the left but
of course would still be very fine going
further to the right
but at the same time we see that there
is an inverse correlation the brighter
the signal is the stronger the staining
index that i'm getting
the lower the compensation requirement
for this given label
should be
so i'm talking here about a conjugate so
a combination of an antibody
and a fluorochrome
as i have an antibody conjugate that
creates a lower signal so that is more
on the left here in this optimal range
we can tolerate that there is more
compensation requirement towards other
channels
because the overall signal intensity
will be smaller so the overall
spillover the amount of spill over life
will be less the number of photons if
you want that
unintentionally is detected on a
different channel is less and so we have
less impact on the resolution in this
channel let's go through a couple of
examples to further illustrate that
this is the model for our weak
weakly expressed antigen so typically we
would be
more on the left with our staining of
course
to be realistic however we don't want to
be too much on the left so that the
spill over from other
floor chrome sickness could crea
compromise our staining index could
compromise the distribution broadness of
the background population and we could
have problems in separating this antigen
so we want to ideally or minimally first
have
a certain staining index that would
allow us to have a certain spreading in
the background without putting the
detection of this antigen at risk and
ideally of course with
maybe even higher staining index we
would find a conjugate a dye selected
for this antigen that causes less
spillover that's the ideal case of
course
if we go to
a modulated antigen which are already
mentioned as probably the most difficult
situation or the most difficult
expression characteristic to manage
we want to make sure that we have a
really bright dye here for this antigen
because we have to think also about
these events on the cells that have a
very low expression density and of
course there will be in this modulated
case also cells that have a very high
expression density and that might cause
a problem so if you just think about the
dye brightness
really high staining index we might
forget about the impact that we have on
other signals so we want to move this
die or we want to find a conjugate that
is lower on the y-axis here
where we could accept maybe even less
brightness
which is seen here as the minimal
situation of course in an ideal case we
would not even
sacrifice brightness but we just find a
conjugate that has less compensation
requirements because here we also have
to think about the very bright events
that could cause a lot of spreading in
other channels
and finally a gating marker here so
think of this cd4 again maybe think of
the cd4pe that we have seen very bright
signal but also we see that it's a
little bit off the ideal area that we
want so
we'll have a very bright signal with a
lot of compensation requirement and that
compromises maybe the detection of other
sickness in our panels so we want to
make sure
that
we would have less compensation
requirement less spillover into other
channels from such a very discreetly
separated antigen and therefore we can
to achieve this we can sacrifice
brightness a lot even
um you see these
this button that still lies in the
optimal range more on the left and of
course ideally we would
have the situation on the lower right
where we still have a very strong signal
but the fluorochrome creates very little
spillover
and
what we
are going to have
is a situation where
for the detection of this antigen we can
have even a very strong spreading
background without compromising
the identification of the
positive cells here
just as a real life example
on this slide i put cd19 so this is not
a very intricate case
and we can see that
there's a lot of dyes that lie here in
this optimal range
where the most
favorable
performances are found
for the polymath eyes that you see on
the lower right like the supernova v428
that have a very high staining index
very strong separation but very little
spill over to adjacent channels to
channels on the same laser here in this
case on the violet laser
and so we can use these channels
for for instance cd19 while there could
be a lot of background spreading in this
channel from other markers without
having any problems here and having a
good separation
okay so this was about the fluorochromes
and the antigen expression levels and
maybe
not to forget also the spillover that is
associated with this now i want to bring
in also the biology so the expression
pattern
the expression patterns
that
would pair basically with the
fluorochrome emissions and antigen
expression densities and characteristics
so to illustrate the significance of
that we have two plots here
these are plots out of
identical panels with regard to the
specificities that were stained here
however with the exception of just the
cdx pc 5.5 on the y-axis the nine other
specificities have different dye labels
on the left versus on the right but
still the group of dies that we selected
the labels from is also identical on the
left and the right so same specificities
same die selections but we have
basically swapped the labels
between the different specificities on
the left
in a different way than on the right
with the exception of just the cdx pc
5.5 so the same antibody on the same
sample with the same label on the left
is able to detect this fragile
population while on the right it's
basically completely lost
so there must be a great significance to
the expression patterns to what kind of
sickness i find on the respective cells
here that i'm probing for this cdx pc
5.5 expression
so the sensitivity for this single
antigen is really a function
of all labels present on these cells
and the key to understand this is really
to think about the biological expression
patterns of the antigens i put a couple
of examples here so yes six different
examples this by no means is exhaustive
you see there's exclusion and that there
is a co-expression with a modulated
antigen always discrete antigens
i just want to focus at this point in
time only those on those that are
red in in red and green frames
um in order to
illustrate the principle or the way of
thinking a bit
so
on the upper left we have a critical
situation as indicated by the red color
because the data spreading that we see
from the lineage marker
into the other channel where we want to
detect the coexpressed marker
is impacting the resolution and
sensitivity that we can obtain here
so this is a real bad choice regarding
the fluorochrome for the lineage marker
and for the coexpress marker
but in the middle we see the green frame
which is indicated as unaffected or
let's say non-compromised
and here still
as indicated by the hinged quadrant line
that you might see into the y direction
we still have a fluorochrome that would
cause spreading from the y-axis
into the x-axis but for this situation
we have selected antigens that have a
parent descendant relationship
so this means
that
those cells that are labeled with a dye
that causes spreading into the other
channels do not occur without a strong
expression of these other labels that
would be compromised so we only have
double positives here
because the marker on the x-axis is the
parent
but still the fluorochromes are the same
of course we have not changed the
fluorochromes we just have matched the
biology
now in a very smart way
with the
fluorochrome characteristics with their
spillover characteristics specifically
so we can
also put all these biological
relationships into such an antigen tree
here we see that there are parent
relationships as we move down the tree
and then in each
hierarchy level we have basically
siblings that also have specific
relationships which could be an
exclusion for instance
so here with the green arrows i have
indicated parent relationships parent
descended relationships so cd4 and cd8
would be children of cd3
so
the labels that we are using for four
and eight may well have a lot of spill
over affecting the channel where we
detect cd3 because cd3 is always
positive on these cd4 and cb8 positive
cells it's the parent so we don't see
here cells that have four and eight but
no cd3 so there's no background
population that could be
broadened and that could affect the
detection of cd3
same holds true for all the lineage
markers here in this hierarchy 3 56 19
16 14 they are all children of cd45 so
we can use labors that have a lot of
spillover into the channel where we
detect cd5 without experiencing any
problems
different situation here so for instance
in the same model
same hierarchy model that we have here
cd56 might be a marker whose
co-expression i want to detect on cd3 so
this would be the situation that we see
on the right so we want to avoid that
cd3 label has a spill over into the
channel where we detect the cd56 label
however if it would be the other way
around if the descendant would have a
spill over into the cd3 label we would
not have an issue because then
we don't see any broadening of a city 56
positive background population that
could
harm here the detection of cd3 cells
and
as another example
maybe cd16 cd14 you may know that
monocytes could be classified as cd60
negative
cd16 intermediate and cd60 bright so
classical and non-classical monocytes
and if we want to have a very good
delineation of this co-expression
patterns we should choose
um
labels here for 14 s16 that have very
little spilled over so that we can
really very clearly and in a very crisp
way delineate this coexpression pattern
here
we also of course have in this
in this
antigen tree we have antigens that would
not occur together
on the same cell for exclusion situation
which allows us to use labels that have
mutual spillover
so just as an example cd56 and cd19
would not occur together rcd3 and cd14
would not occur together so we can
afford a lot of spillover between the
respective labels as we would have a
situation that is
indicated here on the right in this
stylized plot
when we create these trees it's not only
just for fanciness i think it can really
help us think about
the antibody panels and
which selections might impact
our resolution and our delineation
population and which fluorochrome
selections may not be that that
impactful so as an example i've been
talking about cd3
avoidance of cds3 labels built over into
56 if you want to see the double
positives the same holds true for all
the other antigens that are also
co-expressed
on the cd4 as you see the channel and
the children cd4 and cd8 if those labels
affect cd56 resolution then of course we
will see this also while we are looking
at cd3 cd56 double positive cells so
these relationships
the way the trees are built here are
really inherited and so whatever holds
true
for the siblings at the same hierarchy
level also is inherited to the children
in the next line so i think that's very
powerful so you could really understand
that between certain branches exclusions
and coexpressions
really help
how to select the fluorochromes
appropriately so that you not run into
surprises when you look at maybe here
3d56 having not taken into account that
the children of cd4 and cd8 are also
expressed on cd3 and may impact 56
resolution
so finally i want to
add a couple of words on antibody
stacking typically you can stack
antibodies that are not expressed on the
same cell however you might have to make
sure that these different differential
or excluding cell populations are really
identifiable so just as an example if
you look into the t cell compartment
typically you will not find cells that
do co-express a late differentiation
marker and a marker that is rather on
naive and central memory cells so these
would not occur together however you
have no chance to
delineate the t-shirts that are either
positive for 57 or ccr7 so you never
must throw them into the same channel
even if they would not occur on the same
cell
different case for instance as an
example b cell cd 24 could be stacked on
a tc cd3 because we can delineate cd
the b cells very
clear cut by cd 19 whereas cd3 will
never be expressed on cd19 cells so here
we have
the possibility to clearly identify the
exploding population that's a very
important
aspect of that and this could allow us
to stack antibodies in one channel why
would you want to do this
probably the most important reason is
you maybe do not have a hardware with 18
channels or the possibility to detect 16
80 20 markers maybe you can do only
eight so you are forced to think about
this stacking and there's nothing bad
about it it's done properly
it could work very well it's even used
in some diagnostic applications today
and this is just another
example here with antibody stacking
where i added also a yellow case so you
might stack for instance monocyte cd14
together with the three t cell however
you must be
clear about that you can only
discriminate this by the different side
scatter
of the higher side scatter of smaller
size versus the lower side scatter of
cd3 so there is a certain risk
associated with these kind of stackings
so this was what i wanted to share with
you about
fluorochromes antigen expression density
spillover
and the biology of the expression
patterns and how these all these things
impact data spreading and obtainable
resolution and signal intensity
effective separation of sickness and now
i would like to hand over to my
colleague matt who's going to give you
the
angle of fuel
with regard to instrumentation
and the management of signals and light
in the
instrument
thank you michael i appreciate that warm
introduction
and so what we get to do is move in to
the instrumentation light management and
software side of the presentation
and uh it's best summarized by
asking not what you can do to manage
your instrument but what your instrument
can do to help you create a better
experiment and so with that in mind i
would introduce the cytoflex platform
and
there's a lot we could talk about with
the cytoflex platform as an instrument
but what we really want to focus on here
is it's designed to
reduce noise and manage light and so
with that in mind
we want to focus on some principles in
this presentation
and
i i want the viewers to really walk away
with two concepts
the first is that compensation does not
cause data spreading it only reveals it
and that measurement error is the root
cause of data spreading
compensation then is a calculation
applied to measured data and an effect
is simply a computational correction of
a physical arrangement of light
compensation cannot improve data quality
and quality comes from optimized
chemistry and instrument settings
what an instrument measures is
predominantly influenced by the panel
design that michael's covered earlier in
this presentation
how it measures light and the impact of
the error in this process is the
underlying contributor to data spreading
to this end instrument detection
improvements are really improvements in
light management which is what we
decided we were going to focus on here
in this part of the presentation
similar to the results based approach to
panel design the architecture and
software scaffolds within the citaflex
platform were designed to reduce data
spreading by reducing measurement error
starting with our detectors avalanche
photodiodes or apds were chosen over
pmts or photomultiplier tubes due to
their high quantum efficiency
highly consistent reproducibility and
the small area upon which detection is
accomplished
of course avalanche photodiodes are not
a new component of optical detection
systems but they're but their adoption
into flow cytometry instruments was led
by the advent of the cytoflex
moving over
optics are often divided into excitation
and emission and while we'll focus on
the apd as a central feature
of the detection optics we would do a
disservice to the instrument design not
to mention the excitation optics
this the focal piece in this system is
the composite objective paired with the
flow cell which gives a high in a value
while reducing optical noise by 10 fold
versus legacy flow cytometry systems
lastly the way in which the data is
digitized is a critical feature of a
high quality instrument
all electronic systems create noise
without fail
what separates a modern system from a
legacy system is the way in which that
noise contribution is recognized and
mitigated without affecting or
adulterating signal quality
we're able to reduce data spreading by
reducing measurement error so to start
let's take a look at a sample run on two
different instruments
for this example we show cd4 conjugated
to fico urethra and commonly called pe
as a tale of two detectors we're able to
compare a legacy system with a pmt to an
apd in the cytoflex in the visual
indicating that
with settings as closest can be made
between dissimilar systems using the
same samples
the contribution of spread by a detector
with a lower quantum efficiency and a
larger detection surface is significant
and even more exacerbated when using a
bright and abundant fluorochrome like pe
if we were to tabulate this in a
spreading index table we would see the
contribution of this light into several
other channels of detection
going into more detail of the optic
system we see a few more major
components
notably the integrated beam shaping
paired to the flow cell is a part of the
composite objective structure
following this carefully crafted
excitation
the emission detection system ahead of
the apd relies on a novel wdm or
wavelength division multiplexer this
technology was borrowed from the best in
class optical design optical design in
the telecom industry
the wdm relies on a bandpass-only
construction and arrangement of filters
versus traditional pod or tree type
designs that rely on part or hole on the
presence of long short and bandpass
filters paired together
by simplifying the collection of emitted
light and simply touching the light less
and reducing loss in those touch points
the cytoplex is able to deliver a signal
to the detector with reduced light
interactions and photon loss
lastly we arrive at the aforementioned
apd which has been described in some
detail previously
here we would highlight the higher than
80 percent quantum efficiency and active
electronic noise management apparatus
embedded in the side effects as a
further method of noise reduction and
thus signal enhancement
here we see sphero rainbow particles
commonly called apic beads resolved
across the many channels available on
the cytoflex lx
resolution between the peaks is a
non-biological indicator of instrument
sensitivity
in the lowest part of this graphic we're
able to see the resolution of the
specific infrared channel detection
however
as most researchers would tell you
beads are not cells and so we also need
to talk about the cells that are
available
uh or talk about cellular analysis on
the cytoflex instrumentation
from 2019 a poster presented at the ice
excito meeting we see that we were able
to
highlight the discrimination of dead
cells within an intracellular
multicolored flow cytometry experiment
zooming in on a subset of this data
we're able to see
a few different pieces of data that
really highlight the apd sensitivity and
resolution in this biological sample
which is whole bloody edta uh whole
blood anticoagula
whole blood treated with
edta
uh by detecting the monocytes as you can
see in the third panel on the right in
the infrared channel we're able to give
the instrument more freedom to
detect the co-expressed molecules in
other channels
where higher sensitivity is required
because of the reproducible
semiconductor construction found in the
apd we're able to take advantage of an
inherent linearity that can be
calibrated to display a linear response
to varied mfis or mean fluorescent
intensities
this distinct advantage over pmts allows
the user to make adjustments to the gain
without changing the compensation
calculation and we're going to dive into
this now so that you can see how a user
would take advantage
of this system within the site expert
software on the cytoflex platform
from a user perspective this advantage
is called gain independent compensation
and it's accessed in the compensation
menu of the site expert software
following the simple three-step process
outlined in this slide gives users the
ability to reduce the resampling time
when designing an experiment
first suggested gains are available as
part of the baseline file for each lot
of qc beads and they can be used to
create the compensation calculation
following this either beads or cells can
be used to acquire single color stains
as beads have become popular for this
purpose we account for that here
unstained cells can be used alongside
the beads as an experimental unseen
value
following the creation of the
compensation table this information can
be imported into a new experiment as
seen in the graphic on the right hand
side of the slide
lastly the gain for each detector can be
changed to account for biological
differences in samples without affecting
the compensation calculation
as alluded to in the previous slide we
see a graphic here outlining the process
for standard flow cytometry experiment
without the benefit of gain independent
compensation
the focus for comparison here starts
after the import compensation matrix
step seen in the upper right hand corner
here we can see that any changes to the
voltage applied to a specific pmt would
broadly require a reacquisition of the
single and experimental samples at a
minimum
this step is often the most time
time
i'm sorry this step is often the most
iterative and time consuming especially
in panels with high dimensionality
as an advantage the cytoflex offers a
simplified workflow
you can see that the platform largely
eliminates the need for this
re-acquisition model required in a
legacy flow cytometer summarized again
in the graphic here you see that the
adjustments required in the gain would
translate in the compensation table
without the reacquisition of
single-colored stain samples thus
allowing researchers to move through
their samples quickly and into analysis
without unnecessary delay
this can often save more than 50 percent
of lost time
during an experiment
to summarize the cytoflex platform
offerings we see that an instrument with
exquisite sensitivity the ability to
detect small particles for analysis in a
benchtop platform
an extensive set of repositionable band
pass filters that can be moved to suit
different experimental needs
the ability to upgrade a system by
activating additional detection channels
and intuitive software that's meant to
facilitate multi-color analysis
highlighted by the gain independent
compensation
the cytoflex cytoflex s and cytoflex lx
offer a variety of laser and detector
configurations that can be scaled to
meet each individual researcher's needs
and we take a moment here to highlight
the newest member of the family the
cytoflex srt
offering up to four lasers in 15 colors
and available to users
who want to experience the same
analytical model that they've gotten in
the site expert and cytoflex platform
only only in a sorter so that they can
make their sales available for
downstream analysis and processing
and with that michael and i thank you
for your attention and we welcome any
questions
thank you michael and matthew for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
how do i figure out the surface
expression of antigens weak versus
modulated versus dense bimodal when
designing an antibody panel
yeah maybe here's michael maybe i can
take this one
well one thing is there is meanwhile a
couple of publications out that really
try to assess the number of copies so
the expression density of certain
antigens
on on various types of cells
however i really have to say i prefer
really to do something very simple
i just visit the websites of vendors and
look at
the pe staining of this antigen how it
looks like
this typically gives me a very good
impression with very bright dye
what is basically the shape
of the staining is it a really modulated
staining is it a
bimodal staining or rather dim staining
and from from this real data
which from my point of view has the
advantage over
counting the the copies of of certain
molecules on the cell surface gives me
real the impression what i want what i'm
looking for the real staining pattern
that i want to manage and that i want to
deal with
so this would be just my way to do it
thank you michael
the next question we have
you mentioned the goldilocks principle
of die brightness could you name the
best dies to use
in case bright emission and low
spillover at the same time as needed as
you indicated for modulated markers
yes the modulated markers are the most
difficult to manage
because on the one hand we have very
bright signals on the other hand we have
a portion of cells that will have a very
low expression density
and specifically also for those we not
only want to have a bright eye but also
a range of the spectrum a channel
where we are pretty clean from spill
over from other dies
so thinking about these three criteria i
would say the top channel from my point
of view
is really the supernova 428
brilliant violet 421 super bright
there's a couple of different
makes here that are
non-tandem
violet dyes violet polymers that really
deliver great brightness that are
working on a very clean part of the
spectrum with hardly any spillover
and also are very modest with regard to
their spill over to other channels so
that would be my number one number
second the second one would be the apc
for me if you work with non-tandem dyes
like alexa floor 700 alexa flow 750 on
the red laser you get a very clean
channel
typically you don't see spill over from
other
dies a lot
and
it depends on the on the full panel
design but apc also is one of the
candidates that typically allows for
for good assessment of
the modulated dies and finally pe also
is a good candidate where pe still
might have certain tandem dye leakage
spill over
maybe not so clean as the others
thank you michael i believe our next
question is for matthew
when was the srt launched and how many
are in use at this time
hey that's a great question uh the srt
was launched earlier this year in march
of 2021 and i don't have the number uh
offhand but we've had
a
growing amount of interest in the srt
especially from our existing size likes
community but also from a number of
people that are looking for a benchtop
sorting solution
with a very straightforward
you know software interface and a high
degree of usability
thank you matthew our next question here
so this person asks when to do
compensation using cells or beads which
one is the first choice because there's
quite a difference in the result when
using cells or beads
maybe i can i can take this one this is
really um
there are
different opinions on that
i
personally rather follow the opinion
that using cells if possible
um
so possible
means there is
a sufficient frequency of cells that
express a certain antibody that you
would stain for compensation
and also the intensity of the staining
allows for good separation from
background if these two prerequisites
are provided
then i would prefer cellular staining
because it gives the authentic
background the authentic
autofluorescence but on the other hand
you can also argue well the beef
staining is much more standardizable
than
uh using
a sample of some donor and ex-beaver
material which of course can differ
between donors so there are two two
opinions i think both uh both are
correct somehow both have their their
their place
all right thank you again michael the
next question is for matthew i believe
we can combine a few here
so the question is what software
analysis packages do you recommend for
cytoflex data analysis once data is
transferred to a separate computer post
acquisition do these packages run on
both mac and pc computers
and the next question do you want me to
ask it too
yeah go for it how do the data analysis
software like flojo affect affected by
adp's and pmt
all right both of these questions are
really good so the cytoflex creates um
the standard uh scs file that's uh
pretty much the industry norm across the
board for flowcytometers it should work
on your plus cytometry analysis software
of choice
of course at beckman we do offer
caluza
as
one of our software
analysis packages and we are also proud
to offer the cloud-based cytobank
product for
dimensional analysis and
visualization reduction
all right great thank you again matthew
our next question are there simple basic
rules to follow in the rather
complicated antigen trees you have shown
yes
there are so the the antigen trees
should give you an idea about the
biological relationships so you have
parent markers and then subpopulation
markers that go as descendants or
children here i think that if you put
this in this type of tree the most basic
rules would be if you go up the tree
please
you can
tolerate spill over but please avoid
spill over as you go down the tree as
you go from parents to descendants and i
think maybe a second rule that is
helpful if you are in the in just one
hierarchy in the tree so if you have
siblings if you want
avoid spill over unless you know that
these citrix do exclude like in case of
of ce 1956 for instance i think these
two rules
nearly cover it all already
thank you michael the next question here
is from matthew again
for a cytoflex cytometer can i take a
filter from the red laser chamber and
place it into the yellow laser chamber
thank you
um absolutely the
the filters that are used in the
cytoflex can be moved interchangeably
between different spots so that you can
create custom
configurations that includes moving them
between pods the the mounting apparatus
for each of the filters is the same
across the board so there's no issue
with moving them however you see fit
all right thank you matthew i think the
next question here is from michael
regarding stacking of antibodies is
there a limit of how many antibodies can
be stacked using the same fluorochrome
well
i would say i don't know actually but i
did not run into this yet just to give
you an example um
we just have developed a kit for inner
limb for itself staining where we have
stacked 11 antibodies in one channel and
we do not face any issues i think
specifically when you when you want to
create the so-called dump channels so
when you want to exclude certain
lineages
from your your further analysis
i don't see that you quickly would run
into into
an issue here um i think
the the
limiting factor maybe is more what makes
sense
so this is probably more limiting than
the technical aspect here
thank you michael our next question is
there a significant difference in the
spillover seen in tandem dies from lot
to lot asr antibodies for the same
target antigen and obtained from the
same manufacturer
yeah it depends a little bit on what you
consider a significant difference
typically you would see a lot a lot
differences
which is basically
related to the fact that
it's impossible
to
generate two lots of tendon dyes that
are exactly the same you
can tailor the manufacturing process in
a way that these two lots come very
close to each other and that is
typically seen if you have
manufacturers that follow iso 9001
processes cgmp-like processes that
really try to avoid any variability and
and problems
but
i would say a hundred percent
uh identical tandem dies from two
different lots are more like the
exception
thank you michael looks like we have one
more question here
is there a typical bc set of
fluorochromes conjugated to antibodies
recognizing the main types of leukocytes
yes and no
so again this goes a little bit along
what is apparent what is a strong
marker what is a rather meat marker so
here if you say
main type of leukocytes we probably look
into villages
so chrome orange for instance is a
relatively dim dye we use this for a pan
glucoside parent marker cd45
for the dura clone kits we have used a
con a uniform setting where all the
t-cell gating markers 3 4 and 8 are
sitting on the red laser with a lot of
spill over but as these markers are
either extruding or apparent
are really really strongly expressed uh
this gives us a good a good separation
still while these red dyes do not
influence the other lasers a lot so
these are the considerations that you
might take into account here a real
typical set
maybe a cd45 from orange that is maybe a
real typical choice
all right thank you michael thank you
both again um michael and matthew do
either of you have final comments for
our audience
yeah uh thanks for asking so there were
a number of questions that were asked
that
we're going to follow up with those
individual questions by email the the
answer to them would have been very
complex and
a little bit of opinion so
we will respond to your questions in a
timely fashion and we thank you for
offering them even if we couldn't answer
them here
i think thank you matt i would not have
nothing to add here to what you said
exactly that's the way we're going to do
that
all right thank you again michael and
matthew for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank labrus and our sponsor beckmann
culture life sciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye